machen sie ihnen eine kleine freude
sagen sie sie würden am 22 spd wählen
und freute sich
[Musik]
die sprechen
die
mario bleibt im moment hier
ich bin sofort wieder da ok peter
service spd ja das spritzen können
erkennen sie warten machen sie ihnen
eine kleine freude sagen sie sie würden
am 22 spd will nun freut er sich dass
die leute sofort spd sehen erst mal so
[Applaus]
weiland frau lange das spd vergessen
sich ja egal was passiert auf keinen
fall das wort ist der verstand
okay wir was uns normal
kommt mal kommen noch von da bitte so
ein stück weiter die kamera nimmt ihn
damit also jetzt von der spd
es tut aber nichts zur sache vermietet
die band hat das gefühl er wird
gebraucht
es gibt ja noch was von mir
ich glaube an sie denken ich denke ich
denke und ich werde auch mein kreuz
machen
[Applaus]
die leute auch dass man so ein bisschen
auch auf die tiere eingeht
danke
und kommt von hier
generation person
aschersleben
uns liegen
wilder westen
manchester
[Applaus]